in the past few videos we've talked
about how different recommenders can
help with cost performance and security
in your google cloud projects
for enterprises and larger organizations
it's likely that you'll have many
projects
in order to take full advantage of the
benefits from recommendations you might
need to scale how you handle them such
as incorporating them into a pipeline to
programmatically manage them
today let's go over some tips for how an
enterprise could leverage
recommendations at scale and show you
how to export your recommendations to
bigquery so that they can be reviewed
across your organization
the benefits of active assist work great
even if you only have one project but
they really begin to shine in an
organization with lots of projects
in each project various recommenders
will help you apply the principle of
least privilege for security minimize
resource waste from workloads and
maximize the performance of business
critical applications
because of the increased scale of
operations in a large organization
you'll want to review and take action on
recommendations with minimal
administrative work and time
what this looks like for your
organization will be unique to your
workloads infrastructure security and
processes
while the exact details depend on what
works best for you we recommend a
three-phased approach for adopting
recommenders at scale
as you move through these phases at your
own pace the potential for automation
increases
let's start with the first phase
accessing recommendations through the
recommendation hub in the google cloud
console
the recommendation hub is the simplest
way of accessing and managing
recommendations in your projects and
organization
reviewing recommendations in the
recommendation hub will familiarize you
with different recommenders available so
that you can think about how you might
like to prioritize them when building a
pipeline in a later phase
working from the console also includes
being able to set up a bigquery data
transfer to export your recommendations
to a bigquery data set
when you do this two tables will be
generated recommender export where the
recommendations are exported and insight
export where the insights that help you
focus on important patterns are exported
insights can provide additional context
to recommendations or they can be used
independently
by exporting recommendations to bigquery
you're able to look at details for
project level recommendations across
your organization
with that ability you can expand by
creating dashboards to help you
visualize and report the potential
impact of applying recommendations
once you're familiarized with the
console and with the data exported to
bigquery the next phase of recommenders
at scales is to use the apis
all of the recommendation data that you
can access through the recommender hub
or the bigquery export is also available
via an api
the recommendation resource returned by
the api will include lots of information
about a single recommendation including
the priority the expected impact and the
status of the recommendation such as
active or dismissed
you can also use an api to return
insights just like in the bigquery
exports insights can provide additional
context for associated recommendations
for example a recommendation from the
iim policy recommender to reduce the
permissions for a user
may have an associated insight that
includes the permissions that have been
used in the past 90 days and therefore
should not be removed
you can use the api to view
recommendations and insights as well as
to update their status if you choose to
take action on them
when getting started with the api you'll
probably want to require manual review
but you can start introducing automation
to help scale and handle more
recommendations this can also help lay
the foundation for the third phase
integrating recommendations into your
organization's devops pipelines
if your organization has a
well-established devops strategy changes
to your cloud infrastructure might be
managed through continuous integration
and continuous deployment processes
the goal for scaling recommendations
should be to automate the review
analysis
and implementation
for example you could set up cloud run
to regularly retrieve recommendations
via the api and then automatically
generate a pull request in your
infrastructure as code repository for
that recommended change
that pull request can be reviewed by an
administrative team and if accepted and
merged the included recommendation can
move on in the pipeline and subsequently
be applied to your cloud infrastructure
by incorporating recommendations into
your ci cd pipeline you can proactively
monitor recommendations
apply changes that are kept consistent
in code can easily be reviewed tested
and rolled back using the same processes
used for the rest of your infrastructure
this level of automation and integration
is ideal for large organizations and
enterprises but no matter what scale
you're working with you can still always
take advantage of recommendations
it can also be helpful to start slow and
take the time to get familiar with
recommendations and how they impact your
cloud infrastructure before you
implement a full-blown automation
process
we've taken a look at the recommendation
hub before so now let's take a look at
how we can get those recommendations
into bigquery
you can do this by setting up a bigquery
data transfer with the recommendations
as the source
to do that you'll need to have the
recommendations exporter role assigned
on your organization's iim policy this
will give you access to the
organization's recommendations across
projects
start in the recommendation hub where
you can find the export button at the
top of the page
the first step is to provide the
destination project where the
recommendation data will be stored
the destination project can be any
project that you have access to but
you'll need to have the following
permissions for that project
bigquery data sets create bigquery
transfers get bigquery transfers update
resource manager projects update service
usage services enable and service usage
services git
in addition the bigquery api and
bigquery transfer api will need to be
enabled for that project
the next step is to configure the
transfer with a few details like name
schedule and a target bigquery data set
when it comes to choosing a schedule
you'll have the option of daily weekly
monthly or your own custom schedule
you'll also be able to configure
notifications via email if the transfer
fails or publish to a pub sub topic when
a transfer completes
once complete you'll be able to see your
new bigquery data transfer details in
the console and it should begin
populating data within about two days
once the transfer has had a chance to
run you'll see those two tables we
mentioned earlier in your selected
bigquery data set recommendation export
and insight export we'll include a link
to the documentation where you can see
the full table schema recommendations
will also have a field for associated
insights so you can look up any insight
details in the insight exports table
with recommendation data exported to
bigquery you'll be able to write custom
queries to analyze recommendations from
there you can expand by exporting to
data studio or google sheets where you
can further analyze for patterns and
opportunities to optimize
you can also begin to automate by
accessing that recommender api and
follow that up by including
recommendations into programmatic
processes as part of your established ci
cd pipelines
recommendations are available for all
google cloud users if your organization
has a support package you'll also have
access to the full api and bigquery
export we'll include a link in the
description with more information
we'll also include some links in the
description if you'd like to find even
more information and guidance on using
active assisted scale
and remember
the right solution depends on your
organization and what makes sense for
you don't be afraid to implement these
over time instead of jumping immediately
to the most complicated solution
stay tuned for more videos and thanks
for watching